[Música]
los Ecuatorianos irán a las urnas el 5
de febrero para decidir si aprueban o no
las propuestas de una serie de reformas
a la constitución del país una propuesta
que viene desde el ejecutivo el
presidente Guillermo lasso son en total
8 las preguntas a las que deben
responder los ciudadanos vamos a verlas
aquí en detalle hay una pregunta sobre
la extradición de Ecuatorianos que hayan
cometido delitos de carácter
transnacional también la conformación de
un consejo fiscal que elija y también
que regule a las personas que trabajan
en la fiscalía general también la
reducción en el número de asambleístas
de ese país también otra de las
preguntas Busca aprobar o no Si se
desarrolla un proceso para regular la
proliferación de movimientos políticos
también una nueva manera para la
designación de las autoridades de
control en ese país suramericano
Asimismo hay una pregunta con la que se
busca hacer un cambio en el proceso de
designación del Consejo de participación
ciudadana hay una pregunta también en
cuanto al cuidado ambiental y también
para aprobar la posible entrega o no de
compensaciones a las comunidades que
apoyan la generación de servicios
ambientales pues para analizar este tema
esta reforma importante para la
democracia y para la política
ecuatoriana hemos invitado a Ana Belén
Cordero ella es asambleísta nacional por
el movimiento creo y también está con
nosotros Paola cabezas ellas asambleísta
nacional por el movimiento Revolución
ciudadana a las dos les doy la
bienvenida al programa también les
recuerdo que nuestros televidentes
ustedes Sí claro ustedes también hacen
parte de este programa pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
Facebook y también en instagram nos
encuentran como arroba
franz24_s@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal y la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios numeral el debate f2
todo junto no olviden también que todos
los contenidos de nuestro programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Ana Belén gracias Ana Belén por estar
con nosotros aquí en France 24 y
comienzo preguntándole por estas
reformas a la Constitución de Ecuador
son reformas necesarias está adaptando
la Carta Magna de este país a una
realidad mucho más acertada a la
actualidad ecuatoriana Cuál es su
impresión
primero buenas noches y un saludo a
todos los televidentes que nos están
viendo en estos momentos tanto a nivel
nacional como internacional y
efectivamente esta reforma o esta
consulta pero popular que está
planteando el presidente Guillermo lasso
como un plebiscito una reforma parcial a
la constitución del Ecuador es necesaria
es urgente y es Útil para los ciudadanos
Y por qué porque tiene un hilo conductor
importante que es la lucha transnacional
contra el narcotráfico y el crimen
organizado es una lucha a favor de las
instituciones de una mejora en la
institucional de la institucionalidad
del país y es una lucha contra la
minería ilegal Esos son los tres ejes
primordiales de esta Constitución y se
espera que este domingo cinco de febrero
sean los Ecuatorianos que tengan una voz
y que tengan una decisión en función de
estos tres primordiales problemas que
tienen los Ecuatorianos son cerca de 13
millones 450 mil personas las que están
habilitadas para votar en esta consulta
que daría una renovación algunos puntos
importantes
de la Constitución saludo ahora a Paola
también Bienvenida al programa Gracias
por estar con nosotros y la misma
pregunta Paola como Punto de partida son
reformas necesarias
son reformas que necesita la
Constitución de Ecuador en este momento
dada la coyuntura que vive el país o
cuál es su punto de vista sobre estas
reformas sobre estas referendo
qué tal Santiago muy buenas noches
Saludos a usted y a toda la audiencia
que nos puede escuchar No solamente en
el Ecuador lo puede ver y escuchar en el
Ecuador sino en el mundo mire la
consulta popular tiene varios objetivos
y son objetivos coyunturales para el
gobierno del presidente Guillermo lasso
que ante el debilitamiento de su
gobierno sí indiscutiblemente estamos
hablando que cerca del 85% de los
Ecuatorianos no aprueban su gobierno
aprovecha una coyuntura electoral
justamente que estamos por elegir
autoridades locales para introducir este
debate en justamente en la sociedad
ecuatoriana sobre elementos que sí
coincido con la colega Ana Belén que hay
en este momento en el Ecuador
dificultades en cuanto a la inseguridad
y están utilizando el miedo el temor
para poner en el debate el tema de la
extradición hay un asunto muy importante
que hay que relevar sobre el tema de la
extradición primero la extradición
no va a expulsar a todos los
delincuentes como es justamente
el encuadre que está utilizando el
gobierno para llevar a los Ecuatorianos
a la Sur decir que van a expulsar a
todos los delincuentes como si se
tratara Pues de sacar a la basura del
país creo que es demagógico y poco ético
para no explicarle en realidad el
contexto de lo que representa para el
Ecuador la extradición puede ser un
elemento pero no Resuelve los problemas
de inseguridad que está viviendo el país
Colombia México son países que cuentan
con este instrumento y siguen siendo
países en donde el narcotráfico sigue
permeando la sociedad en donde continúan
en el caso de Colombia tiene
veinticuatro muertes violentas por cien
mil habitantes está México con la misma
cantidad y el Ecuador en este caso está
superando a Colombia y a México y
creeríamos que esta pregunta no es la
que Resuelve los problemas de
inseguridad que tiene el país porque hay
otros delitos que son los que justamente
atravesando la tranquilidad que tienen
los Ecuatorianos como es el sicariato la
excursión la violencia que eso no lo va
a resolver la extradición Paola continuó
con usted para hacer la ronda la inversa
usted considera que este referendo va a
servir como una especie de termómetro
para medir qué tal está la popularidad
del presidente lazo debido a estos
inconvenientes que ha venido presentando
Ecuador en términos de seguridad las
problemáticas que ha presentado en las
cárceles va a ser una forma también en
la que los Ecuatorianos van a expresarle
su desacuerdo o acuerdo en cuanto al
desempeño que ha tenido como jefe de
estado
bueno la consulta popular la ha
promovido el presidente lazo él fue el
que firmó el decreto y ha invitado a los
Ecuatorianos a votar por estas ocho
preguntas preguntas que si usted me
pregunta hacemos una revisión rápida dos
de las preguntas que se han llevado
justamente al referéndum son las que le
interesan al presidente lasso que son
las preguntas cinco y seis que es donde
en realidad se establece una
reestructuración sobre la selección de
autoridades que es lo que está en el
debate público y que en realidad
llevaría a una desestabilización
institucional porque el presidente lazo
está buscando en estas preguntas que en
realidad los anexos son los que tienen
en realidad el el condumio como diríamos
en el Ecuador Buscar un cambio de
mecanismo de selección de autoridades
que sea esto controlado directamente por
el presidente lasso pero sobre todo los
anexos nos dicen que las autoridades van
a prorrogarse en funciones las que están
actualmente porque los proyectos de ley
los enviarían la asamblea nacional en
donde tendrían cerca de año y medio para
tratarlos entonces lo que nos deja en el
debate público y político es que el
presidente necesita oxígeno necesita
autoridades que lo blinden sobre todo en
la actualidad que está viviendo el
gobierno ciertos casos de corrupción que
vinculan a funcionarios de su gobierno y
a familiares cercanos Ana Belén su
perspectiva sobre estos dos puntos
importantes y esto es un respiro para el
presidente es un barómetro para entender
cómo está su popularidad entre los
Ecuatorianos y también en para entender
cuál es la dinámica de estado que quiere
o propone el presidente el lazo a través
de estas reformas su opinión
Mira yo discrepo con Paola y por qué
discrepo Porque justamente esta consulta
no es una consulta del gobierno de este
gobierno ni del presidente lazo es una
consulta de los ciudadanos hecha y
elaborada en función de las necesidades
de los ciudadanos para los ciudadanos
mucho nos hemos quejado y los ciudadanos
se quejan de que la asamblea nacional el
parlamento legislativo no está en
sintonía con las necesidades de la
ciudadanía y fue en esa escucha activa
hacia los ciudadanos y hacia los
Ecuatorianos que estos son los
principales problemas para enfrentar
mediante una consulta popular
preguntándoles o a los Ecuatorianos qué
si estar del lado correcto de la
historia es enfrentar el crimen
transnacional el narcotráfico el crimen
organizado la minería ilegal vimos hace
pocos días como el gobierno del
presidente Gustavo Petro en Colombia
extraditó al hermano de La senadora
Piedad Córdoba hacia los Estados Unidos
sabemos que en el Ecuador en estos
momentos existen aproximadamente 100
pedidos de extradición hacia los Estados
Unidos Yo creo que es una herramienta Es
un paso importante
luchar contra el crimen organizado
obviamente y desde luego no lo soluciona
todos los problemas porque hay que ir
trabajando de la mano con organismos
internacionales y con otros países en
esta lucha transnacional contra el
crimen organizado pero desde luego son
para y por los ciudadanos que se están
tratando estas preguntas y en relación a
la elección y nominación de autoridades
en cuanto al consejo de participación
ciudadana ese Frankenstein de cinco
cabezas que se creó en la Constitución
correísta de dos mil ocho donde para los
que nos están viendo en estos momentos
que no conocen como las legislación
constitucional en el Ecuador en el
Ecuador existen al momento cinco poderes
montesquiu debe estar retorciéndose en
la tumba porque la constitución del
correísmo creó unos cinco poderes y Este
quinto poder es el que elige autoridades
Imagínese usted que cuatro personas en
el país eligen y concentran la
nominación de setenta y tres autoridades
qué es lo que se propone consulta
popular que esa facultad vuelva al
legislativo a la asamblea nacional
primero como lo hacen todos los países
del mundo y segundo con total
transparencia Y por qué me refiero a
transparencia porque se disfrazó de
participación ciudadana un consejo
netamente político y en este momento sin
ninguna vergüenza y con total desparpajo
porque también están compitiendo para
llegar al consejo de participación
ciudadana sale un expresidente a
promocionar unos candidatos de un
partido en concreto cuando Debería ser
justamente una participación ciudadana y
no política Entonces se quiere devolver
esos poderes al parlamento al
legislativo donde están representadas
legítimamente cinco partidos políticos
de alcance nacional para que sean ellos
quienes se hagan responsables de la
nominación de autoridades Ana Belén
Paola ya Ustedes han empezado a tocar
algunos de los puntos de esta propuesta
tenemos poco menos de 30 minutos para
mirar estos ocho puntos de este
referendo que va a ser nuestra guía de
ruta para el resto del programa
analicemos los más que podamos de estos
puntos que Pro referendo ya Ustedes han
hablado del tema de extradición quiero
dar un par de puntadas adicionales sobre
este tema para cerrarlo y empezar a
avanzar con los otros siete que nos
quedan entonces la extradición hay
quienes dicen que es necesario para este
país justamente para empezar a hacer
frente a la situación que se está
viviendo allí con diferentes cárteles
del narcotráfico lo vemos también en las
dificultades que ha tenido el gobierno
para hacer frente a la crisis carcelaria
donde justamente se enfrentan diferentes
bandas delincuenciales por control de
territorio en donde hay tráfico de
drogas o bueno ya es conocido que
Ecuador se está convirtiendo en una
especie de Job de distribución de de
droga procedente de Colombia Bolivia
Brasil y de Perú Pero esto en qué va a
aportar o cómo va a ayudar a solucionar
el tema de la inseguridad que se está
viviendo en este momento comienzo
entonces para hacer la ronda la inversa
Ana Belén pero muy puntual por favor
porque tenemos ocho temas para analizar
Muchas gracias Sí primero es un Punto de
partida es un punto inicial no a este
punto de decir que es un desincentivo
para las personas que cometen crímenes
transnacionales crímenes organizados
como es el narcotráfico la trata de
personas los sicariatos las extorsiones
es un desincentivo a decir ah perfecto
yo no me voy a quedar aquí en esta
cárcel aquí en el Ecuador haciendo de
las mías sino que voy a ir a una cárcel
a un sistema donde afortunadamente
tienen un un sistema judicial bastante
Imparcial y Expedito como lo es en
Estados Unidos y en otros países del
mundo porque los convenios de
extradición son con muchos países y es
un desincentivo y es un primer paso para
luchar contra esa inseguridad que nos
aqueja aquí en el Ecuador y que no es de
ahora y no es de este gobierno viene
desde arrastrado desde gobiernos
anteriores porque justamente en un
inicio Éramos un lugar de paso y ahora
somos una especie como usted lo ha dicho
una especie de Job justamente para el
cultivo y la comercialización hacia
Estados Unidos y Europa
Paola su per sobre este tema
primero porque los sicarios los
extorsionadores los femicidas que son
justamente los crímenes que se están en
alza en el país este tipo de crímenes no
son extraditables Y eso es lo que hay
que decirle al país y Ana Belén
repitiendo justamente el discurso de su
gobierno le están diciendo a los
Ecuatorianos que más y más vamos a abrir
las cárceles y vamos a extraditar a
cuatro mil choneros o a Los chone
Killers y a todas las bandas organizadas
que están delinquiendo en el Ecuador y
eso no es real hay una problemática que
Ojalá fuera la que abordar esta consulta
popular y es justamente la inversión
social porque en provincias como la mía
y tú lo sabes Ana Belén que es donde se
concentra en realidad en una provincia
de frontera estamos cerca con Colombia y
es la provincia en donde se ha
convertido en el caldo de cultivo
justamente por las políticas
neoliberales del gobierno de Guillermo
lasso que no invierten salud No
invierten educación y los jóvenes se
convierten justamente en dos elementos
que en esta economía
subterránea esta economía esta economía
que justamente vincula a los carteles de
la droga están empujando a los jóvenes
pobres a los jóvenes que no tienen
trabajo a las familias que no tienen una
atención justamente por el gobierno que
debería adicionalmente hacer una
inversión en rehabilitación social
establecer una política de inversión
pero no esperar que Estados Unidos les
haga el trabajo que no ha hecho su
gobierno a cuenta de que van a enviar
delincuentes para que en las cárceles de
Estados Unidos resuelvan lo que debería
resolver en materia de política pública
el gobierno de Guillermo lasso ese es el
problema en realidad central en el país
que están queriendo vender humo sobre
una consulta popular que no resuelve Los
Reales problemas que tiene el país claro
personas más indicadores clarísimos que
nos ha dado la unicef sobre Ecuatorianos
cerca de dos millones de Ecuatorianos
con hambre Entonces eso lo va a resolver
la consulta popular no Y obviamente al
presidente lasso en esta consulta hay
que demostrarle que hay un hartazgo del
pueblo ecuatoriano de sus políticas
económicas pero adicionalmente la
intención maquiavélica que tiene de
cotar las instituciones para ser el que
tome el control solamente concluyo con
esto parece que no les desagrada tanto
el frente porque justamente en los
anexos hablan de una comisión Ciudadana
de selección lo que están haciendo
simplemente es cambiando la correlación
vamos a analizar ciudadanos sino que
vienen cinco de representantes del
ejecutivo que en este caso serían
puestos por el presidente lazo Paola se
me adelanta un poco un poco en el tema
pero debo llevarla llevarla de la mano
hasta el segundo punto de esa consulta
que es esta pregunta del referendo que
plantea la designación de un consejo
fiscal para darle un poco más de
autonomía a la fiscalía general del
estado el consejo se encargaría de
seleccionar y evaluar y sancionar
también a todos los servidores de
de el estado su opinión
Paola Paola me Oye perdón hubo un corte
podría repetirme
del segundo punto del referendo sobre
esta designación de un consejo fiscal
para darle un poco más de autonomía a la
fiscalía en Ecuador su perspectiva sobre
este tema Bueno esa es otra pregunta que
paga favores políticos la fiscal general
del estado que es producto justamente
del trujillato de una consulta popular
de similares características que fue
impulsada en el 2018 que removió a todas
las autoridades y dejó la fiscal general
del estado como parte justamente de
estos favores políticos ahora la quieren
prorrogar en funciones y no solamente
eso prorrogarla en funciones pero
entregarle plenos poderes Qué establece
la normativa en el Ecuador que el
consejo de la judicatura se encarga
justamente del área administrativa de la
función judicial los jueces y Fiscales
se encargan de eso de ejercer justicia o
de administrar justicia lo que están
haciendo en este momento es quitándole
la parte administrativa a la fiscalía al
de la judicatura para entregarle a la
fiscalía que es la que ahora va a
evaluar va a Designar va a ser todos las
las labores que debería ser el ente
administrativo claro lo que no
entendemos como la fiscal porque ojo hay
una un ente de selección que se crea que
es nominado por la misma fiscal Entonces
le están entregando plenos poderes a una
fiscal que indiscutiblemente no ha
resuelto muchos problemas de la justicia
en el país muchas deudas por
investigaciones importantes sobre todo
en el caso de inapets del ex presidente
Moreno Ana Belén su opinión sobre este
segundo punto del referendo
bueno primero yo no creo que debemos ver
personas ni hablar de la fiscal en
concreto porque si nos ponemos a poner
nombres y apellidos a los fiscales
podemos también hablar de los fiscales y
cien sobre cien yo creo que lo
importante aquí es hablar justamente de
esa autonomía que debe tener la fiscalía
y por qué debe tener autonomía Paola
sabe que no miento cuando le digo a los
televidentes en este momento que ya son
nueve años que no se han hecho concursos
de Fiscales y es importante que
precisamente sea la fiscalía con esa
autonomía sin depender del Consejo de la
judicatura que pueda organizar nuevos
concursos evaluar Fiscales hemos visto
con asombro todos los Ecuatorianos y el
mundo entero que a veces se dejan en
libertad o solamente con prisión
preventiva sin juzgar y sin formular
cargos a delincuentes que han cometido
delitos transnacionales y no se puede la
fiscalía ni la señora fiscal general del
estado sancionar a esos Fiscales porque
es apotear la tiene el consejo de la
judicatura Entonces es importante
separar esos poderes dar autonomía para
que definitivamente este consejo fiscal
sea el que tenga estas potestades
administrativas así como lo tienen los
jueces desde el consejo de la judicatura
tercer punto comienzo con Ana Belén
preguntándole por esta reducción en el
número de asambleístas de acuerdo a
otros criterios por los porcentajes
dependiendo de los territorios allá en
Ecuador actualmente la asamblea tiene
137 legisladores y es un país de más o
menos unos 18 millones de habitantes
Anabelle en su opinión
Bueno yo creo que es importante tener en
consideración que la Constitución de
2008 que se dio en la Constituyente
cuando presidía el gobierno Rafael
Correa estableció escaños fijos eso qué
quiere decir que de aquí a 10 15 o 20
años cuando la población crezca porque
Es evidente su cíclico demográficamente
hablando vamos a seguir teniendo esos
mismos escaños lo que quiere decir que
no es representativa esos esos escaños o
esas constitución en función de la
demografía lo que está proponiendo la
consulta popular es establecer escaños
en función de la demografía del
crecimiento de la población ahora
acabamos en el año
dos edición de ese censo deberán
establecerse los escaños establecidos en
función de la cantidad de de habitantes
y usted sabía por ejemplo que una
provincia que es la más numerosa que es
guayas donde se encuentra la segunda
ciudad más importante Guayaquil en el
país su voto la esos asambleístas vale
dieciséis veces menos que el de un
asambleísta en Galápagos Yo creo que es
importante que exista representatividad
porque los mejores parlamentos son
aquellos que se encuentran mejor
representados para estar más en mayor
sintonía con la ciudadanía la asamblea
nacional y los asambleístas no todos Yo
no quiero generalizar porque hay
asambleístas valiosos que debemos
todavía y hay una factura pendiente con
la ciudadanía en muchos temas Como por
ejemplo el tema laboral el tema de
educación y el tema salud Paola su
opinión
bueno para Ana Belén Cordero desde el
privilegio una un parlamento como
representado es donde no está en
poblaciones indígenas afrodescendientes
donde no estén mujeres Rurales donde no
esté la representación real de un país
sabe lo que pasa con esta y esta
pregunta gana nueve provincias del país
y justamente Qué casualidad las
provincias donde viven las poblaciones
indígenas van a quedarse sin
representación bajan de tres
asambleístas aún asambleísta sabe lo que
representa eso que el que va a tener
plata o el cacique es el que va a
hacerse de esa curul y no va a haber una
representación real en el parlamento los
migrantes que justamente gracias a la
constitución del 2008 vienen una
representación dentro del parlamento que
son los que le inyectan recursos a la
economía ecuatoriana más de cuatro mil
millones han enviado los migrantes a la
economía del país sin embargo el
presidente lasso los quiere dejar sin
representación eliminar los seis escaños
que tienen a dos eso no es democrático
eso no es y no es una representación
Real de lo que somos como Ecuatorianos
deberíamos en este caso es más no
entiendo cómo es que quieren reducir
asambleístas Pero por otro lado inflar
la lista de asambleístas nacionales y
sobre un mecanismo en donde la lista es
cerrada van a elegir asambleístas que no
conocen asambleas nacionales que no
conocen cuando lo más democrático y real
Es que la asambleísta sea electo por su
comunidad sea electo justamente por la
cosmovisión a la que representa por eso
es completamente
desatinada esta pregunta porque no va a
ajustar a la realidad de la
representación claro tienen los
Ecuatorianos y dejarían por fuera la
representación de muchos sectores como
como lo que le planteo ahora mujeres
indígenas afrodescendientes sobre todo
jóvenes Paola en el cuarto punto también
hay algo interesante dice esta reducción
de los movimientos políticos el objetivo
que tiene esa cuarta pregunta de acuerdo
a lo que dice el documento es regular y
controlar la proliferación de los en
Ecuador Esto entonces Cómo afecta el
espectro político del país es para
evitar atomización política y concentrar
el espectro político del país en en
menos movimientos políticos esto que
garantizaría o que le ayudaría a la
salud para la democracia del Ecuador o
esto iría en detrimento de la Democracia
ecuatoriana
Santiago esto pudimos hacerlo resuelto
en una reforma al código de la
Democracia hoy en la asamblea estamos
tratando reformas al código de la
Democracia pero como son esas preguntas
humo y enganche porque están justamente
aprovechando el debilitamiento del
sistema de partidos el debilitamiento de
la misma asamblea nacional optan por
estas preguntas que Sencillamente
pudieron haber sido resueltas en una
reforma al código de la Democracia Esto
no es Es más existe Norma expresa para
que la el Consejo Nacional electoral
supervise si los partidos políticos
dentro de sus adherentes cumplen con los
requisitos si las firmas están acorde
todo eso está establecido dentro de la
norma lo que están haciendo con esta
pregunta es vender más humo porque en
realidad lo que le interesa al país o le
interesa al presidente lasso son las
preguntas cinco y seis no me quiero
desalineado lo demás son temas que
pudieron haberse resuelto dentro de la
asamblea nacional pero no necesariamente
llevarle a los Ecuatorianos o una
consulta popular por esta pregunta ya
vamos a pasar a las preguntas cinco y
seis Ana Belén Quiero conocer su opinión
sobre este tema de la reducción de los
movimientos políticos cortina de humo
como dice Paola en lo absoluto de hecho
esa reducción del número de asambleístas
va de la mano con esta pregunta la
reducción de los movimientos políticos
de acuerdo a la constitución en el
Ecuador tenemos movimientos y partidos
en el Al momento de 13 millones de
habitantes tenemos aproximadamente
279 entre partidos y movimientos que
únicamente cinco son partidos es decir
solo cinco tienen alcance Nacional los
demás son movimientos que utilizan
recursos públicos a lo largo de todos
estos años en todos los comicios
electorales se destinan más de 150
millones de dólares en entregar estos
recursos para los comicios electorales
es importante que tengamos un sistema de
partidos fortalecido que permita
justamente fortalecer esos liderazgos a
nivel nacional y por eso va de la mano
con la reducción de asambleístas que va
a fortalecer los liderazgos nacionales
en este caso los asambleístas nacionales
cuando vienen los comicios electorales
siempre nos decimos Ah pero es que no
hay cuadros no hay liderazgos nacionales
etcétera pues este es el momento Y esa
es la oportunidad ya no más partidos de
alquiler porque sabemos que se han
alquilado partidos en muchos momentos o
se han vendido partidos políticos o peor
aún hay mucho riesgo de que los partidos
sean financiados por el narcotráfico y
se ve el lugar a la desastrosa marco
política que puede vivir el Ecuador
pasamos a los interesantes puntos 5 y 6
paolana Belén Paola reiterado que estos
son tal vez los puntos más importantes
que quiere destacar el presidente lasso
en esa consulta comienzo a hacer la
ronda entonces con Ana Belén
preguntándole por estos dos puntos que
plantean eliminar la Facultad de
Designar autoridades que tiene el
consejo de participación ustedes ya
estaban dando algunas de las luces pero
profundicemos en este tema Porque es
importante Este cambio porque es
necesario Este cambio Ana Belén
miren todas las democracias sólidas y en
los estados de derecho alrededor de
América Latina de Europa y en general
siempre es el parlamento ese en ese
adecuado sistema de pesos y contrapesos
el que designa autoridades de una terna
consensuada de parte de las distintas
funciones del estado aquí quisieron
inventar el agua tibia en el año 2008
creando este consejo de participación
ciudadana y control social que se
suponía que iba a fomentar la
participación ciudadana cuando lo único
que se hizo fue politizarla ya vimos que
de ese consejo de participación
ciudadana salió un defensor del pueblo
que está en la cárcel salió un contralor
que está que sacó 100 sobre 100 en la
prueba y hoy está prófugo salió algunas
autoridades que hoy no quiero ni
mencionar Entonces yo creo que más allá
del inconveniente estructural del diseño
estructural del Estado para nominar
autoridades desde este ente que no
debería ni existir pero para
desaparecerlo se requiere una
Constituyente hay que vaciarlo de
contenido y devolver a los orígenes Qué
es el parlamento ecuatoriano y muchos me
dirán la asamblea nacional está muy
desprestigiada pero Paola no me dejará
mentir que hay legitimidad en la
asamblea nacional porque existen cinco
partidos políticos legítimamente
representados en ese en este que es le
llamamos del primer poder del estado y
cuando se vaya a elegir de ganar el Sí
en esta pregunta a nuevas autoridades
serán los partidos políticos con las
distintas miradas políticas las que
tendrán que hacerse responsable de esa
determinada nominación de autoridades y
no disfrazarlo de una falsa
participación ciudadana
Paola su momento para explicar estos dos
puntos
Pónganse de acuerdo quieren eliminar
asambleístas porque dicen que la
asamblea más y más no sirve no tiene
representatividad Y ahora resulta que le
quieren devolver a la asamblea nacional
la selección de autoridades quieren
volver a la asamblea o a los a los
congresos del tome y daca del reparto de
la componenda de la compra de votos para
seleccionar autoridades seamos honestos
en realidad lo que quiere el presidente
lazo y por eso es importante revisar los
anexos porque no hay tal interés de
devolverle a la asamblea nacional
supuestamente su facultad de elegir
autoridades primero porque aquí van a en
estas preguntas en el anexo que es ahí
donde está la trampa el cianuro hay
Crean un consejo de selección consejo
que va a estar conformado por la la
representación de cinco autoridades de
El Ejecutivo porque sí son de varias
funciones del Estado pero son vinculadas
al ejecutivo y solamente le dan cuatro
espacios a las a la ciudadanía hablan de
La Academia hablan de ciertos gremios
todo es ambiguo porque no establecen
exactamente quienes van a ser los
representantes de este consejo de
selección ciudadana porque así le llaman
Ahora yo no entiendo por qué están
renegando de el sistema actual que están
utilizando muchos instrumentos del
sistema actual Pónganse de acuerdo ahora
bien hay otro paso que ese es el que nos
preocupa muchísimo más el presidente
dicen los anexos que luego de que
aprobemos esta pregunta
él ejecutivo se va a tomar ciento
ochenta días para elaborar los proyectos
de ley enviarlos a la asamblea nacional
para que luego la asamblea se tome
noventa días más todo el tiempo del
mundo para justamente establecer las
normas para poner a funcionar la
consulta popular pero que hasta que eso
pase van a prorrogar en funciones a las
autoridades que están actualmente saben
A quién quieren prorrogar en funciones
al contralor del contralor que está
preso un controlador que no ha sido
nombrado tienen prorrogar en funciones
el consejo de la judicatura consejo de
la judicatura que está en este momento
completamente legitimado y que no
entendemos Cómo pueden hablar de
extradición cuando hay un consejo de la
judicatura que deja salir a sicarios que
le permite salida a delincuentes
Entonces esta es la real El Real interés
que tiene el presidente lazo primero
impunidad con esto concluyo impunidad
porque prorrogar en funciones a todas
esas estas autoridades coincidirían con
el final de su periodo que lo que quiere
es garantizar que ni la fiscalía ni la
contraloría la investiguen todos los
casos de corrupción que tiene
actualmente su gobierno llegamos al
bloque final del programa para las
preguntas siete de ocho y las
conclusiones de lo que puede dejar este
referendo para la política de la
sociedad ecuatoriana siete y ocho giran
en torno al tema medioambiental
son preguntas que Proponen incorporar un
subsistema de protección hídrica también
un sistema de compensaciones
a incentivos a las personas comunidades
que mejoren el cuidado del medio
ambiente que se levanten algunos
candados que tiene la Constitución
ecuatoriana en este momento que no
permite que estos procesos sean tan
ágiles y
gira en torno básicamente a el material
medioambiental que es un tema Pues de
suma importancia para sobre todo para el
este del Ecuador que es una zona
selvática y que siempre ha estado en el
ojo del huracán en cuanto a la hora de
hablar de política Ana Belén comienzo la
ronda la inversa con usted su
perspectiva sobre estos dos puntos
necesarios el tema medioambiental
efectivamente Estos son dos puntos
importantes que siempre han estado sobre
el tapete y ahora no es la excepción es
importante proteger nuestros recursos
hídricos de hecho el presidente lazo
cuando estuvo en campaña y así lo ha
cumplido dijo que respetaría todos los
recursos que estén a nivel de de la
protección de los de los ojos de agua y
de los recursos hídricos y es importante
los temas medioambientales en función de
ellos que se ha planteado Esta última
pregunta que es parte de este de este
Pilar de tres patas que es la protección
y los incentivos adecuados para la
protección ambiental ahí vemos
justamente Cómo se va a crear estas
áreas de protección hídrica que existen
en una ley principal pero es importante
elevarlas a Rango constitucional por eso
se plantea esta pregunta puntual y
muchos me dirán Bueno pero es que eso
pudo haberse hecho por una reforma legal
en la asamblea nacional primero pensemos
en que hay que tener ese paraguas de
protección constitucional para poder
desglosar o derivar a las cambios
normativos inferiores Entonces esta
pregunta resulta o busca responder a
muchos de los problemas que tenemos con
nuestros temas medioambientales Paola su
perspectiva muy puntual por favor porque
quiero tener buen tiempo para para que
hagan ustedes las conclusiones adelante
Bueno lo acaba de decir Ana Belén esto
lo pudimos hacer dentro de la asamblea
nacional Así es Ana Belén todos estos
temas se pudieron haber resuelto dentro
de la asamblea nacional sin necesidad de
llevar estas dos preguntas que como
muchas de las preguntas de la consulta
popular son preguntas gancho al igual
que ocurrió en la consulta del 2008
donde pusieron que iban a a ponerle casi
cadena perpetua a los violadores de
niños y no ha pasado absolutamente nada
al respecto ponen esta pregunta en la
consulta popular Por qué es necesario
indiscutiblemente hablar de estos temas
en el país hay todo un sector sobre todo
los jóvenes ambientalistas hay un sector
que está muy compenetrado con las
políticas a las políticas ambientales y
buscan obviamente a través de estas
preguntas cautivar a los jóvenes sin
embargo los temas relacionados ya
existen en el ordenamiento
constitucional y legal y en el código
orgánico ambiental eso es lo que hay que
decirle al país y al mundo inclusive
prodigan desarrollarse a través de la
promulgación de por parte del gobierno
sin necesidad que lleguemos a una
consulta popular esto es un Espejismo
más que no va a resolver los problemas
estructurales que tiene el país me queda
un par de minutos para las conclusiones
Ana Belén lo que deja entonces de
perspectiva y expectativa este referendo
que será celebrado en Ecuador este fin
de semana que también ha sido víctima
como en muchos otros sectores y en
muchas otras áreas del planeta víctima
de la desinformación de las campañas a
través de las redes sociales de
comentarios entre los políticos y los
diferentes sectores de este país pero
qué se puede concluir a grandes rasgos
para el cierre del programa Ana Belén
Bueno lo importante es tener en claro
que esta consulta no es una consulta de
los políticos ni de ningún gobierno de
turno Esta es una consulta de la
ciudadanía hecha por ciudadanos para
ciudadanos y efectivamente Busca
resolver los problemas principales de la
ciudadanía Todos siempre mencionan y
dicen esto se podía haber hecho con una
reforma legal Cuántos años lleva la
asamblea nacional en funciones y se
pasan sacando resoluciones y exhortos
que finalmente no resuelven los
problemas por eso esta consulta popular
Busca devolverle a los ciudadanos a los
Ecuatorianos esta respuesta en función
de tomen una decisión que hacer respecto
al luchar contra el crimen organizado
luchar contra esa crisis
institucionalidad que tiene el país y
luchar y afrontar el medio ambiente por
eso este fin de semana son los
Ecuatorianos realizando esos anexos que
no son secretos que deberán tomar una
decisión Paola 40 segundos para su
conclusión 35 segundos de hecho
rápidamente por favor para el cierre
Santiago el presidente Guillermo lasso
es político es un político que está
buscando que a través de la consulta
popular validar Un gobierno que tiene
más del 85% de desaprobación el gobierno
de Guillermo lasso no ha cumplido con
las reales propuestas de campaña que le
hizo al país no hay educación no hay
salud y los problemas de inseguridad que
ha provocado la nula política criminal
es lo que justamente está buscando
resolver con paños tibios con una
consulta popular que la extradición no
va a resolver los problemas reales de
Crimen y de criminalidad de violencia y
sobre todo de hambre y de pobreza Paula
viviendo el Ecuador al gobierno de
Guillermo lasso hay que decirle no en la
consulta popular Paola y Ana Belén
Muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros en el programa gracias por
haber puesto en perspectiva las dos
caras de la moneda de este referendo
para los que no estamos empapados de la
política ecuatoriana interesante este
ejercicio ver los dos lados de la cara
de la moneda Muchísimas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Luis
Fernando Montes y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera ustedes Muchísimas gracias por
la Pueden seguir dejando sus comentarios
a través de las redes sociales y en
sintonía de France 24 siga con nosotros
[Música]